[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire d'un côté on nous dit que
les inégalités dans le monde n'ont
jamais été aussi grande qu'aujourd'hui
et de l'autre on nous répète qu'un
milliard de personnes sont sorties
depuis trente ans de l'extrême pauvreté
et que la population mondiale n'a jamais
été aussi riche mais les ong oxfam vient
d'annoncer qu'aujourd'hui 26 personnes
détiennent davantage que la moitié de la
planète
et l'on sait plus très bien si c'est la
pauvreté le problème ou si c'est la
richesse ou si ce sont les inégalités et
si c'est bien vrai nom c'est ce que nous
dit oxfam sur les inégalités
on est donc invitée oxfam pour en
débattre mais ils n'ont pas voulu venir
en revanche sont venus laurent papy
analystes à l'iref l'institut de
recherches économiques et fiscales
vous avez récemment dénoncé la
méthodologie utilisée par oxfam pour
pointer les inégalités dans le monde
on y reviendra mais d'abord ce sera ma
première question c'est quoi le problème
pour vous la pauvreté la richesse où les
inégalités et via un bon soir on nous
attentons n'a tenté de nous faire croire
pendant la deuxième moitié du xxème
siècle que le problème c'était les
inégalités ou 21e siècle problème serait
la richesse on créerait trop de
richesses moi je pense toujours
comme depuis des siècles que le problème
n'est pas la richesse n'est pas les
inégalités mais la pauvreté
un exemple pour le préciser le soudan et
plus égalitaire que les états unis il
n'empêche
aucun américain envie de vivre au soudan
et on a plutôt des phénomènes obs
inverse qui sont observés donc oui le la
pauvreté est le problème les inégalités
la richesse ne lançons pas une vieille
et rouillée vous êtes fondateur du site
les crises point fr sur les quais lequel
vous dénoncer les erreurs et les
manipulations journalistique mais qui
est aussi un blog économique
il y avait écrit notamment une série d'
analyse portant sur les inégalités dans
le monde
alors à vos yeux le scandale la pauvreté
la richesse ou la différence entre les
deux c'est à dire les inégalités pas
bien sûr qu'en tout cas depuis deux
siècles beaucoup de personnes se battent
contre la pauvreté contre les gens qui
meurent de faim il ya encore vingt-cinq
mille morts de faim par jour 9 millions
par an certes en progrès enfin on n'a
pas encore résolu le problème est bien
entendu si on présente les choses comme
ça on peut dire que la pauvreté en effet
et le premier mal à combattre mais il
est difficile ici de le combattre et
d'avoir des sociétés qui peuvent
fonctionner correctement vos de trop
grandes inégalités
enfin il y en a certains qui disent et
oxfam a l'air de
dire que pour s'attaquer à la pauvreté
il suffit de prendre aux riches pas
caricaturer non plus mais oui c'est un
peu c'est un peu l'idée est simple idée
pascal salin vous êtes économiste
professeur honoraire à l'université
paris dauphine ancien président de la
société du mont pèlerin
fondée en 1947 par frédéric ier karl
popper et milton friedman vous êtes
l'auteur de nombreux livres le dernier
c'est le vrai libéralisme paru en 2010
neuf chez odile jacob
alors pour vous le problème la pauvreté
la richesse où les inégalités c'est
certainement pas les inégalités c'est la
pauvreté oui mais bien entendu il est
souhaitable que ceux qui sont pauvres
puissent changer
mais c'est précisément ce qui arrive
bien souvent lorsqu'on parle des
inégalités on a une vision un moment
donné du temps et on ne se soucie pas du
fait qu'il ya une évolution dans dans la
vie des gens en tout cas ou plutôt que
de parler d' inégalités je préférerais
qu'on parle de diversité
une des caractéristiques des êtres
humains c'est qu'ils sont tous
différents et c'est ça qui fait la
richesse des sociétés humaines
or les êtres humains pour agir y
réfléchisse d'abord qu'il faut réfléchir
avant d'agir et la diversité la manière
de penser des gens conduit à une
diversité dans les activités et par
exemple dans les activités qui ont eu un
caractère mesurable par exemple à
revenus monétaires et herat mais vouloir
la diversité dans l'airé revenu dans le
capital c'est au fond vouloir refuser la
diversité des êtres humains refusent et
la diversité de ce conte que les
économistes appellent le capital humain
il ya une diversité extrême du capital
humain cas pour conséquence une certaine
diversité dans le capital monétaire ou
dans les actifs financiers mais ceci
n'est qu'une conséquence près d'haïfa
rave des économistes vous enseignez à la
sorbonne vous êtes chercheur au
laboratoire phare de la sorbonne vous
êtes l'auteur d'une introduction
inquiète à la macroéconomie c'était paru
aux éditions les petits matins
votre prochain livre s'intitulera fake
state impuissant s'organise
et de l'état en france sa sortie est
prévue en avril au d'édition et à chaud
même question frédéric c'est quoi le
problème
la pauvreté la richesse où les
inégalités même si la pauvreté
effectivement reste combattre et que
même si effectivement on peut se réjouir
peut-être une amélioration de la
situation d'un plus grand nombre
d'humains sur cette planète
je pense que le combattre les inégalités
me paraît une nécessité non pas pour
espérer une société où l'égalitarisme
régnerait c'est pas ça mais c'est que
l'histoire nous montre clairement aussi
que fondées l'expansion économique où la
croissance économique sur des inégalités
est trop grande
effectivement ça nuit à la croissance
économique et preuve en est dans
l'après-guerre dans nos sociétés il ya
eu un effort pour réduire les inégalités
qui a été fait dans le monde occidental
et qui s'est effectivement accompagné
d'une croissance supérieure
donc je crois que c'est parait
effectivement l'un de l'autre n'est pas
une bonne chose à ce qu'amd inégalités
c'est pâques inégalités de revenus ce
n'est pas qu'une égalité de patrimoine
c'est aussi une égalité d'accès c'est à
dire d'accès à la santé à l'éducation et
qui sont effectivement autant d'éléments
essentiels qui vont jouer ensuite sur la
pauvreté c'est à dire effectivement en
permettant à plus d'individus d'être en
meilleure santé d'être mieux éduqués et
là ça rebondit sur la pauvreté
donc si vous voulez il me paraît
essentiel de ne pas isoler tellement les
termes du débat parce que croire que on
va pouvoir s'occuper de la pauvreté sans
par exemple traiter des questions
d'inégalité d'accès ce serait se tromper
parce que la pauvreté ne disparaît pas
par incantations elle ne disparaît pas
parce que demain je ne sais pas on
appauvrirait complètement les personnes
les plus riches c'est pas ça s'est il y
à un effort à faire
kisa effort collectif et public pour
permettre un plus grand nombre
d'individus aussi d'accéder à des choses
qui vont les rendre et les placer en
position de pouvoir maximiser nos
opportunités maximiser leurs chances
mais en même temps il faut pas tout
ramener ça à un individu il faut ramener
aussi à des structures qui parfois bloc
empêche effectivement un accès que ce
soit par exemple on le voit bien dans le
monde
ou parfois souvent selon les jeunes
femmes les filles qui ont parfois moins
accès à certaines choses en terme
d'éducation par exemple que les garçons
bon il ya toutes ces choses là qu'il
faut combattre et en les combattant en
permettant à plus d'égalité
on peut aussi de cette manière
effectivement combattre la pauvreté
parce que les inégalités
ce n'est pas que le revenu et le
patrimoine pour moi c'est très important
d'insister sur les inégalités d'accès
aussi alors très souvent n'ont pointé à
la suite de de plusieurs rapports qui
ont été rendus par les ong oxfam
quand on parle d' inégalités on nous
sort des des affirmations comme celle-ci
26 milliardaire détiendrait davantage
que la moitié la plus pauvre de la de la
population mondiale
alors est ce que c'est vrai c'est à dire
est-ce que 26 milliardaire détiennent
davantage que trois plus trois milliards
et demi de jean-claude pop il n'est pas
d'accord alors la méthodologie qui est
derrière cette affirmation est
extrêmement douteuse voire même
manipulatrice si vous frédéric vous
possédez 10 euros admettons que c'est
votre patrimoine total vous possédez
seulement 10 euros
et bien je peux dire avec la même
méthodologie qu'oxfam que vous détenez
plus que la richesse cumulée de 2
milliards d'êtres humains
pourquoi parce que oxfam se base sur les
statistiques du crédit suisse qui dit
qu' on qui compare les patrimoines nets
des des individus le patrimoine est
c'est ce que vous possédez - vos dettes
et il se trouve que les gars notamment
l'exemple typique qu'on cite souvent les
étudiants américains qui à la sortie de
leurs études ont des dettes qui est
relativement élevé qui se chiffre en
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars ou d'euros total ces mille
milliards de dollars de dettes des
étudiants la bulle de l'endettement des
étudiants qui font partie
statistiquement d'après la méthodologie
d'oxfam des gens qui sont les plus
pauvres de la planète sont plus pauvres
qu un soudanais déjà là ça montre que
utiliser le patrimoine pour évaluer les
inégalités c'est ce que disait frédéric
sarre à celle a même cessé déjà
extrêmement limité vous voulez dire que
dans les pays pauvres on n'a pas de
dette ou en tout cas pas dans ces
proportions là parce que il n'y a pas de
système on ne peut pas s'endetter de
dans une hutte donc en fait les pauvres
pour oxfam
c'est l'étudiant d'harvard d'où vient de
s'endetter pour faire vendre
il est dans les plus pauvres devant et
ça fait baisser les cds puis le
patrimoine des personnes que l'on voit
sur la photo on ne sait pas l'estimé
c'est à dire que le crédit suisse le dit
lui-même look sommes là vous lui même
on ne peut pas estimer le patrimoine de
ces gens là il ya parce qu'on ne sait
pas et non vous ne seriez pas de droit
de propriété donc on ne peut pas le
faire c'est très difficile mais quand on
sommes par exemple et 10% la richesse
cumulée des 10% des plus pauvres de la
planète
on a un chiffre négatif de - 750
milliards donc quand on some les 30%
cumulée soit 2 milliards de personnes de
leur patrimoine cumulé
on a aussi un chiffre négatif donc ça
veut dire que avec 10 euros vous pouvez
très facilement dire que vous n'êtes
plus riche que deux milliards de
personnes réunies donc cette affirmation
la peau mal relève de la manipulation
elle a été elle a été révélée depuis
longtemps et je pense qu'il est urgent
de révéler derrière le les intérêts que
les intérêts idéologiques défend oxfam
plutôt que de s'attarder sur 7 sur cette
statistique qui est relativement fort
oui et non moi j'en veux dire qu oxfam
montre la lune des inégalités le néo
libérale regarde le doigt
effectivement vous avez raison sur ce
point là c'est pas une méthodologie
oxfam c'est d'abord une méthodologie qui
est d'abord crédit suisse et puis c'est
une méthodologie de base vous regardez
le patrimoine des gens il ya des gens
qui ont un patrimoine négatif
et en effet c'est pas les gens qu'on
voit l'image parce qu'ils n'ont rien il
a fallu que la finance un néolibéral
invente des dettes supérieures à l'actif
pour avoir une petite fraction de la
population et c'est pas les des
originaux ça s'appelle le déleste on a
pu s'endetter ont retenu on a eu des
pertes ribbon négatif
non parce qu'il faut que la dette
supérieur votre actif net vous achetez
une maison aux mendes vous avez la
maison en face dans votre patrimoine il
est pas négatif et il est peut être
faible mais n'est pas négatif pour
refaire sa vie au début je suis désolé
quand j'emprunte pour acheter une maison
vous avez acheté la maison j'achète la
raison et à la banque qu'elle dépose à
moi non dans la maison la maison est à
vous parce que vous avez acheté un
nouveau type de propriété et vous avez à
détroit dans le calcul du crédit suisse
ici c'est fini
non mais l'exemple si l'exemple qu'il
donne l'exemple qu'il donne c'est
l'exemple du l'étudiant quels étudiants
ou jeunes actifs
il a un capital de connaissances par
contre un capital culturel qui va
pouvoir valoriser et qui vaut bien plus
que le patrimoine d'une simple maison
parler ce qui est intéressant c'est pas
de regarder les faits de bord que vous
soulevez en effet ce façon un peu
j'alterne dépasse quoi vous avez un
problème et c'est de créer un problème
dans le problème oui effectivement c'est
un petit problème ça représente trois
fois rien non je regarde alors ce qui
permet de dire des absurdités du genre
avec 10 euros je poussais d'autant que
deux milliards de personnes cumulent est
d'accord dire se révèle que l'artistique
gants de boxe femme est complètement
d'accord doc oublions les gens qui ont
des patrimoines est négatif on veut
oublier ceux là peuvent a commencé à
ceux qui à un patrimoine juste nul on va
arriver à dire que les 26 pour les 26
milliardaire dont on parle ils vont pas
avoir 50 % puisque vous avez pas les
négatifs qui vient imputé positif à dire
au revoir un patrimoine de quoi à peu
près 20 ou 30% de la planète et pas
cinquante ans je les veux dire c'est ce
que je dirai je ne nierai pas que ya des
inégalités de là dessus sur les lieux de
patrimoine maintenant
cette statistique montre premièrement
que on ne peut pas faire des généralités
de cette manière et la deuxième chose et
là je vous renvoie aux travaux ternant
dos des photos on ne sait pas estimé le
patrimoine des plus pauvres c'est un
économiste péruvien qui a passé sa vie
dans les bidonvilles du monde entier et
qui regarde qu'est ce qui fait que on
peut se sortir de la misère sortir de la
pauvreté et montre qu'il faut qu'on
reconnaisse ses droits de propriété
cette liberté d'échangé et tant qu'on ne
la reconnaît pas on ne peut même pas la
mesure est donc on ne sait pas combien
quelle est la valeur du patrimoine des
plus pauvres de la planète
pascal sala je voudrais juste prendre un
ou deux exemples pour montrer
l'absurdité de cette à mesure de
désigner des inégalités vous avez par
exemple deux individus qui sont tout à
fait identique
il y en a qui est pannequin cumul du
capital
l'autre ne veut pas ils préfèrent
consommer tout de suite avoir des
satisfactions immédiates plutôt culte et
rieur et alors on va dire il ya
inégalité dans le patrimoine de ces deux
là il faut redistribuer les richesses
c'est une absurdité prenons le cas
voulait dire que deux personnes gagnant
50000 euros par mois donc ils sont plus
il est mieux loti il y en a qui les
défenses intégralement dans une autre
ville cas contraire les écrits
les inégalités entre devons devenir
ainsi d'érable selon ces cas là la
réalité disposent exactement des mêmes
droits mêmes savent ou alors prenons
deux individus qui est pas exactement la
même quantité chaque année mais il y en
a un qui a 25 ans et de 60 ans eh bien
il est évident que celui qui à 25 ans un
capital beaucoup plus faible alors on va
dire là il ya un pauvre parra il faut
plus prendre de l'argent aux riches pour
donner aux pauvres
c'est une absurdité une fois de plus ça
signifie que ces statistiques elles ne
tiennent pas compte de ce qu'ils
fondamental dans la vie humaine qui est
le temps la durée
les gens changent et il projette sur le
futur et le capital est le résultat de
décisions tout au long de la vie des
gens farah ce qu'on en fait que cette
question à l'emploi débattre
indéfiniment parce que c'est toujours la
question de la méthodologie comment
mesure des inégalités de quoi on parle
qu'on dit les inégalités alors de quoi
on parle je pense qu'effectivement il
faut déjà regarder deux trois choses
très précisément et ensuite se rend
compte que si on veut une approche un
peu plus fine
il va falloir entrer dans les détails
alors c'est quoi les trois choses si
vous voulez regarder les inégalités
entre les différents pays vous devez
regarder cette chose qui est aussi tout
aussi imparfaite qui est le pib par
habitant avec tous les problèmes de
calcul ya liés aux taux de change au
pouvoir d'achat ça c'est ensuite il faut
regarder les égalités internes et les
économistes utilisent d'autres outils
pour ça qu'ils le fameux coefficient
gini
c'est à dire que plus vous rapprocher de
1 - c'est bien en tant que tel hélas
rien n'empêche d'assister à une
réduction des inégalités entre les
nations et une augmentation des
inégalités un interne à l'intérieur et
ensuite il ya la troisième version qu'on
regarde les inégalités mondiales comme
si on imaginait que le nom des terrains
un ensemble unifié et on regarde on
compare les choses entre ce genre d'
approche très globale a quand même un
défaut parce que elles ne permettent pas
de voir une réalité book beaucoup plus
précises qu'on peut observer à des
échelons local que l'on peut observer au
niveau de territoires qui font que dans
un même pays on peut avoir par exemple
un indice de développement humain qui va
être plus élevés dans certaines parties
d'un pays et dans d'autres cas beaucoup
plus dégradée
et chacune et chacun des outils qu'on a
par exemple djinnit il a été par exemple
critiqué parce qu'on a dit effectivement
qui ne permet pas de bien mesurer les
inégalités duo par rapport aux bas donc
on a créé un nouveau qui s'appelle plein
10 palma alors lundi spalma qu'est ce
que c'est sait on observe la quantité
enfin la part de revenu ou la masse de
revenus distribués aux 10% comparé aux
40%
donc effectivement qui est venu enrichir
donc si vous voulez en termes de
méthodologie
on observe il ya eu aussi le rapport
conduit par l'équipe de thomas piketty
avec effectivement qui a voulu observer
quelle était la part de revenus captée
par un certain nombre pour voir
effectivement comment les inégalités et
selon ce rapport les inégalités
augmentent donc si vous voulez on peut
débattre de la méthodologie parce
qu'aucune n'est parfaite
dans le fond et que c'est comme
l'histoire des chiffres du chômage les
secousses et les vrais chiffres et faux
chiffres on nous cache on ne les cache
par etc
qu'est ce que l'on peut quand même
observer quand même
entendant ce qu'effectivement un les
inégalités à un terreau des nations
n'ont eu de cesse de croître ces
dernières décennies malgré une réduction
relative des inégalités à l'échelle de
la paix entre les nations
2 que le fait de cette réduction de ces
inégalités on le doit surtout à une part
importante des indiens et des chinois
qui sont sortis effectivement de la
pauvreté
3 si on retire cela on voit que
l''indice gini d'inégalités a légèrement
progressé et que dans le fond on observe
quand même que par exemple la
mondialisation c'est avant toute chose
un processus de redistribution des
inégalités à l'échelle de la planète
dans la mesure où la mondialisation est
avant toute chose une mise en
compétition généralisée des territoires
des hommes des capacités des uns et des
autres et effectivement il suffit pas
juste d'insister sur cette fameuse
égalité des chances mais de voir combien
les structures sociales économiques
institutionnels parfois ne favorise pas
ni la sortie de la pauvreté ni la
réduction des inégalités
alors on peut débattre à l'infini sur la
méthodologie je n'en doute pas mais on
en trouvera jamais qu'on regarde tous
les critères qui existent ou les outils
qu'on a développés combien il est
difficile pour construire le propos sur
inégalités en plus ou en moins
d'observer effectivement les données
empiriques que l'on recueille et à
chaque fois on se rend compte que les
outils qu'on utilise bon bah sont
intéressants mais montre des limites et
donc on en apporte d'où il ya ya ya
quand même une manie depuis quelques
années c'est de pointer à chaque fois de
compter 26 milliardaire ou alors
regardons la suivante c'est les 2153
milliardaire qui possèderait des plus de
richesses que 60% de la population
mondiale c'est là dessus qu'on a assisté
et laissé repris à chaque fois par tous
les médias il ya également alors les 1%
les plus riches possèdent deux fois plus
de richesses que 90% de la population
mondiale
sauf que là ça devient commence à
devenir plus critique parce que là on
parle plus des milliardaires on commence
à parler nous les 1% des plus riches au
niveau de la population mondiale il ya
une bonne partie de la population
française là et que tout à coup nous qui
nous voyons comme au contraire très
pauvre par rapport à ces milliardaires
qui possèdent autant que la moitié de la
planète
là tout à coup on commence à être dedans
parce qu'on est dans les 1 % beaucoup
d'entre nous en france on donnait 1 %
les plus aisés vous avez fait ce calcul
olivier berruyer pour être dans les airs
pour ça il faut avoir tout à fait mais
si vous voulez quand vous êtes dans ses
seins denses quelques centaines des
milliers d'euros pour répondre à votre
question à cent mille euros je crois que
les 1% les plus riches de la planète
tout à fait mais si vous voulez ce
qu'apporte le rapport oxfam c'est je
pense déjà un premier indice de où on en
est sûr la planète
on peut sortir des petits pois vous avez
raison on peut sortir un gars d histoire
des patrimoines et gatif pour en gros
vous avez un pour cent de la population
mondiale qui a 50 % du patrimoine
et si vous prenez les 10% les plus
grosses et 80% à peu près voilà arrêtons
là après le reste je suis d'accord et
frédéric trop creuser sur des inégalités
mondiales comme si on était un seul pays
ça a pas grand chose comme 6 26
milliards d'eur pouvait être
l'équivalent à fait parce qu'il ya
encore plus bête quand même j'insiste là
dessus il ya le
dix hommes les plus riches du monde ont
un patrimoine supérieur au pib cumulé
des 85 pays les plus pauvres
ça c'est vraiment là c'est de la
désinformation c'est là on compte d'un
côté des richesses accumulées pendant
toute une existence par des hommes face
aux revenus de 85 pays mais qui sont les
revenus annuels c'est comme si en france
dans notre pays il ya le château de
versailles est nécessaire dans le pays
mais j'ai tout dire ça et c'était l'idée
c'est de faire passer le message c'est
beaucoup c'est ça la vie qu'ils ont
remise à l'échangé il a mangé parfois
sexuellement c'est vrai après ça vous
donne un air de grande part pas l'eau
patrimoine et la richesse annuelle comme
au hockey mais comment vous arrivez à
comparer la fortune marc darnault
qu'entre 10 et 100 milliards mais ces
poissons milliards comment on essaie de
faire passer 100 milliards aux gens je
peux vous donner l'info c'est 100
milliards ferrer 6 1 milliards ou 100
milliards c'est tellement gros vous
prenez plus mais ça permet de montrer et
de tangibilité certaines choses on
pourrait dire oui ce bug est pas bête
mais en tout cas c'est de comparer ces
les revenus de bernard arnault avec le
pib de la france là ça a un sens ce
n'est pas le patrimoine de bernard
arnault avec les revenus de la france
oui puis on peut aussi dire que le pdg
de ce fait d'oxfam gagne 600 vols
salaire de quelqu'un qui vit au burundi
c'est bon on peut faire beaucoup de
statistiques pour faire peur pour dire
qu' on doit absolument taxer les plus
riches pauvres là où je suis d'accord
avec avec frédéric ferrasse c'est que
l'inégalité de patrimoine la mesure
donne très peu d'information s'est il
faut la prendre pour ce qu'elle est elle
peut avoir son intérêt mais il ya tout
un tas d'os indicateur qui peuvent être
intéressants comme la mortalité
infantile l'espérance de vie le taux
d'alphabétisation est pour moi quand on
regarde tous ces indicateurs dans leur
ensemble qui ont tous leurs
imperfections on en arrive facilement à
la conclusion qu'en fait le monde n'a
jamais été aussi égalitaire il n'y a
jamais eu autant aussi peu de personnes
qui étaient en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté ya jamais eu aussi peu de
personnes qui sont pas allés à l'école
voilà donc c'est pas parfait mais 2020
et la meilleure année que l'humanité ait
jamais connue 2021 sera la meilleure
année que l'humanité n'ait jamais que
s'il n'y a pas de guerre mais en 1913 a
été la meilleure année
l'humanité j'avais connu tout à fait on
peut toujours très dire un événement
catastrophique mais en dehors de ça la
situation le monde est moins violent le
monde est plus riche donc vraiment il
faut déjà partir de ce constat là les
inégalités sont ne reflète pas la
réalité du monde
l'autre élément que j'aimerais juste
ajouter c'est que on a peut-être des
inégalités énormes j'ai peut-être une
inégalité énorme de revenus entre
bernard arnault ou même de patrimoine
trop bernard arnaud et moi mais ma vie
au quotidien
elle est bien plus proche de celle de
bernard arnault que de celle d'un d'un
soudanais c'est à dire que moi j'ai
comme bernard arnault j'ai peut-être pas
le téléphone dernier cri comme lui mais
j'ai aussi un téléphone qui permet de
communiquer je peux aller si j'ai envie
à l'autre bout du monde avec un billet
d'avion alors j'ai peut-être pas y aller
tous les jours j'ai pas y aller en jet
privé et ma vie va beaucoup plus
ressembler à celle de bernard arnault
que celle d'un soudanais est passé dans
les nababs saurait vous êtes dans les
bourses européennes un smicard français
il est même si sa vie n'est pas
forcément la plus simple je le jure je
reconnais ça il les fait partie des six
pour cent du top 6 pour cent des gens
qui donnent le guen le plus de revenus
au monde donc il faut vraiment prendre
du recul sur la situation
il est vrai qu'au sein des pays en
france par exemple ou dans d'autres pays
développés il y a des tendances
inégalitaire de patrimoine et de revenus
qui peuvent peuvent être préoccupantes à
l'échelle mondiale grâce à l'ouverture
de plus en plus de pays à l'économie de
marché
on a une chute dramatique des inégalités
de santé d'éducation et ça c'est
vraiment le la réussite de l'économie de
marché ou de papier en même temps est-ce
qu'il n'est pas un peu absurde de dire
que ce picard français fait partie des 6
% les plus riches entre guillerets le
plus d'argent 2 qui viennent le plus
d'argent le fait de gagner mille cinq
cent mille mille et quelques euros une
fois qu'on a enlevé le les charges mille
et quelques euros en france c'est être
moins riche que quelqu'un qui gagnerait
1000 euros au burundi alors vous avez
changé les plans gagne moins on a on
l'est tout est plus cher ma revanche en
france tout est gratuit enfin les
services publics sont gratuits et pas au
bureau ni
sa vie c'est pas grave sur les feuilles
avec nos impôts oui d'accord pour ce qui
est du spi car il en profite le mans
vous êtes un exemple extrêmement
intéressant parce que c'est un des pays
les modèles en afrique qui s'est ouvert
à l'économie de marché et qui
aujourd'hui à une des économies les plus
florissantes et qui à éradiquer
complètement ce la misère dans son pays
donc vraiment le bon dit-on explique
faraz de remarques par rapport à ce qui
est dit ce qui est très intéressante
prendre l'exemple du smic parce
qu'effectivement si on ne descend pas
trop bas dans l'échelle des revenus
c'est bien parce que les pouvoirs
publics sont intervenus abandonné et que
pourquoi il n'y a pas les mêmes écarts
entre revenus et patrimoine c'est bien
parce qu'à un moment donné on a créé un
smig
après la seconde guerre mondiale qu on a
transformé qu'on a amélioré et qui c'est
qui est devenu un smic en 70 et qui fait
qu'effectivement ça a permis d'ailleurs
pour cet essai de limiter aussi une
certaine ampleur dans les inégalités
c'est une première chose et c'est
intéressant de voir le rôle aussi de la
puissance publique
il suffit de penser après guerre une des
marchandises à sion du revenu qui a eu
lieu à travers effectivement les revenus
transfert à travers la création 58 des
allocations chômage qui ont permis
effectivement d'amortir la situation
pour des individus ne pas se retrouver
dans la grande pauvreté ou dans la
misère
c'est un alors par rapport à cette vertu
de l'économie de marché
je voudrais quand même amené une nuance
parce que il y avait une promesse dans
l'est dans les théories économiques qui
disait qu effectivement quand les
nations vont se spécialiser
là où on disait il avait le facteur de
production le plus abondant et ben ça va
permettre progressivement à une
égalisation entre les entre les nations
deux économistes récents comment dire
maskin et kramer qui ont masqué n'étant
prix nobel en 2007 fait une étude et se
rend compte qu'au contraire que quand
ces pays qui étaient autrefois moins
ouverts se sont ouverts et
libéralisation il observe comment dire
une progression des inégalités et maskin
se demande pourquoi donc que s'est il
passé alors et il va prendre à
contre-pied cette théorie qui veut qu
effectivement une nation se spécialise
par exemple les pays les plus pauvres
qui ont une main d'oeuvre abondante
devrait se spécialiser dans des biens
qui nécessite une main d'oeuvre
abondante et bon marché ils sont en
compte de quoi que il serait un tort de
prendre une main-d'oeuvre homogène que
la main d'oeuvre est hétérogène et à
partir du moment où cette libéralisation
ce fait est bien
les travailleurs les plus qualifiés des
pays en développement se détache
s'éloigne comment dire de leurs on va
dire des autres qui sont moins qualifiés
se rapproche de caumont dire des
travailleurs au comment dire mieux
rémunérer des pays riches et que les
industries exportatrices des pays en
question où les firmes qui travaillent
dans ces pays vont payer plus ses
salariés que les autres donc ce qui fait
que les moins qualifiés à la fois se
détachent des salariés les plus riches
et en même temps se détache de leur
propre cour citoyens qui eux sont plus
qualifiés donc ce qui fait que dans la
distribution des richesses maskin et
kramer montre très bien à ce moment là
que ce sont les plus qualifiés
finalement deux des pays en
développement qui vont profiter de ce
surcroît de libéralisation et pas les
autres
ce qui a pour effet l'inégalité et
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent et je termine
là dessus maskin c'est qu'au contraire
il faut élever le niveau de compétence
par l'éducation est haute pour permettre
d'élever la qualification le niveau de
qualification de la main d'or donc c'est
très intéressant parce que il faut
toujours rentrer alors sans être trop
long que ce soit dans les inégalités
dans la redistribution des revenus dans
des choses de plus en plus fine pour
éviter les trucs un peu trop trop gros
quoi je vous arrête en fait une pause et
on se retrouve on continue ce débat
juste après
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé sur tesla si vous
voulez est assez symptomatique du reste
vous avez une déconnexion complète entre
la valeur et le prix si vous prenez la
valorisation boursière c'est à dire on
est monté jusqu'à 165 milliards pour une
boîte qui depuis le début père en cumulé
6 milliards et demi je ne validerai pas
la valorisation actuelle qui est
complètement décorrélé des fondamentaux
en effet mais après il y a tout de même
les aspects dans cette société qui
peuvent être valorisés à une certaine un
certain montant au delà en tout cas de
et voitures en elle même il y à la
technologie du logiciel qui est à
l'intérieur et il ya également les
batteries qui peuvent être vendus ou la
technologie qui peuvent être vendus à
d'autres personnes ils vont 350 mille
voitures
ça veut dire que vous valoriser la
voiture entre 400 et 500 mille dollars
la voiture c'est une manipulation de
cours pur et dur
[Musique]
le numérique c'est aimer aujourd'hui 4 %
des gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
tous les citoyens qui utilisent par
exemple des ordinateurs polluent la
planète
à chaque fois qu'on a une requête
internet qu'on envoie un email
qu'on l'ait qu'une photo sur instagram
ça a un impact carbone un email envoyé
avec une pièce jointe
puis c'est l'équivalent d'une ampoule
allumée pendant une heure comme celle ci
peu de gens ont conscience que le
numérique pollue pire encore ils pensent
que le numérique est un outil qui
permettrait de réduire la consommation
d'énergie le numérique est en quelque
sorte un pharmaco en pharma concède un
mot grec ancien qui veut dire à la être
à la fois remède est poison c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il faut
utiliser avec
avec sagesse avec mesure c'est ce qui
fera le plus de bien à la planète
[Musique]
on reprend d'autres débat sur les
inégalités sont elles si importante que
cela avec laurent tapie qui a les listes
à lirey fait qu'olivier berruyer le
fondateur du site les crises avec pascal
salin qui était que de myst et frédéric
farade qui est lui aussi économistes
quand on parle d' inégalités on fait des
comparaisons comme on la vit un peu
hasardeuse entre des gens et des pays
entre des revenus et des patrimoines
entre des milliardaires et la moitié de
la population on compare beaucoup moins
souvent avec ce qui était le passé sous
louis xiv les inégalités videmment bien
plus grande en france qu' aujourd'hui
néanmoins louis xiv avait été parfois
moins riche que sultan rentrait qui
était le grand mogol de dinde est en
revanche le niveau de vie des indiens et
des français est elle-même ce qui creuse
la presse et les révolutions
industrielles c'est parce qu'il ya une
révolution industrielle en france
d'abord en angleterre puis en france que
tout à coup les niveaux de vie vont se
fait par et entre les français les
indiens les américains et les africains
et cetera pascal salin dujeux travaille
là dessus et en tchéquie d'égalité
n'était pas bien plus grande
il ya 300 ans qu'aujourd'hui oui mais je
crois qu'il faut renoncer à s'intéresser
à des statistiques concernant le gie a
été qu'ils s'agissent de l'histoire ou
de l'époque actuelle
parce que on en a discuté tout à l'heure
il ya tout plein de raisons qui
permettent de dire que tout
toutes ces prétendus mesure des
inégalités sont absurdes et on parle
d'eux
de distribution des richesses illégal ou
de redistribution
ce qui est une expression également
contestable parce que ça laisse supposer
implicitement que les richesses
appartiennent à la collectivité ou à
l'état et que eux et elles doivent être
réels doivent être répartis de manière
égalitaire en fonction des statistiques
que l'on que l'on fournit et bien ça me
paraît parfaitement discutable il
faudrait arrêter de parler voulait dire
que chacun créant ses propres richesses
exactement il n'y a pas à les comparer
les richesses créées n'est pas
distribuée et donc à n'est pas un n'a
pas être redistribuées mais pourquoi
justement on fait des statistiques et
des études empiriques sur ce qu'on
appelle les inégalités parce que ça
justifie la politique économique de
redistribution ça permet aux politiciens
d'exister il se ferait on trouve
toujours une majorité de gens pour
essayer de prendre deux des ressources à
d'autres et l'état par conséquent sous
prétexte de réduire les inégalités crée
des inégalités
puisqu'il le il vole davantage de
ressources à certains cas d'autres les
brésil égalité ce sont celles là et non
pas celles qui sont ivy bridge si vous
pensez de cette analyse je pense que
c'est facile d'avoir ce genre de
discours quand on fait pas partie des
900 millions de personnes qui ont faim
en fait en ce moment
deuxième point sur la partie impression
en vendant une partie plus philosophique
est intéressant justement c'est une
vision libérale plus chimiquement pur
que vous nous que vous nous donnez là
après ça renvoie des problématiques qui
sont aussi la morale qu'ils sont
qu'est-ce que deux sont des communautés
la liberté est une fait partie des
devises de la république il ya aussi
égalité et fraternité
comment derrière vous pouvez avoir une
cité qui fonctionne si vous en avez une
toute petite partie qui sent mais je
dirais pas les foules pendant que la
grande partie de la population on trime
injustement voit une partie de la
richesse qu'elle crée qui est capté par
les autres ce que vous dites là ça s'est
créé vous allez créer elle a été aussi
capté un capter vous en parlait dès lors
autant louis xiv les nobles ont bien
captée puis da par l'héritage vous
entretenez c'est différent cela elles
ont été captées par la colonisation il a
été captée de bien des façons sur la
planète donc la question c'est comment
on trouve un juste équilibre on est bien
d'accord on veut pas dire on va pas tout
prendre aux riches pour donner aux
pauvres
ça sent ça va pas non plus résoudre tous
les problèmes des pauvres mais comment
on fait tenir une société et surtout
comment on voit l'être humain là dedans
et ça c'est vrai que c est lors d'un
discours économique mais ça renvoie je
pense à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
profond sur qu'est ce qu'une société que
de papier vous avez fait le calcul si
l'on confisqué la fortune des
milliardaires celle qu'on monte et qu'on
l'a répartissait entre les plus pauvres
puisque c'est ça qu'on compare à chaque
fois vingt six milliardaires 3 milliards
et demi de gens ça ferait combien pour
les pour les pauvres on augmenterait le
revenu moyen de quelques centaines
d'euros de 20 50 % et ce pendant une
année à condition d'avoir réussi à
vendre tous les actifs donc ils
s'apprêtent change de sens euros à la
fin et juste pour une année pour acheter
ça me changerait pas radicalement la vie
de ces gens mais là où je suis d'accord
c'est que c'est au delà de la question
économique de la manipulation des idées
que oxfam pourrait faire c'est avant
tout une question morale et la question
derrière la richesse c est ce qu il ya
eu un vol est ce que bernard arnault a
volé est ce que est ce qu'il a il a
acquis cette richesse de manière
légitime bah bill gates il s'est enrichi
jeu personne ne nie çà et là il a gagné
des milliards de dollars mais quand on
achète un ordinateur à monsieur bill
gates qu'on achète 1000 euros un
ordinateur c'est qu'on considère que
l'ordinateur qu'on lui achète vaut plus
que les 1000 euros qu'on détient et lui
inversement
bill gates et considère que les minéraux
vous détenez valent plus que
l'ordinateur qu'il a fait fabriquer dans
son entreprise
donc là il ya eu un échange où tout le
monde ya gagné personnes exploitées
l'autre et même si moi je les achetais
je suis beaucoup
moins riche que lui j'ai gagné j'ai et
il a transformé la vie de milliards de
personnes grâce à ces ordinateurs parce
que on a pu être plus productif parce
qu'on a pu trouver un métier grâce à ça
parce qu'on a pu apprendre des choses
parce qu'on a pu rencontrer des gens et
donc il faut vraiment voir je pense la
question de la richesse sur est-ce que
la richesse a été bien ou mal acquises
et là dessus le débat n'est pas sûr
qu'elle répartit répartition quelle
distribution est idéal c est ce que j'ai
acquis la richesse de manière légitime
celle de manière légitime ou pas est-ce
que je les acquis parce que l'état m'a
offert une rente
parce que je suis monsieur dassault et
j'ai des marchés publics
est-ce que je l'étais je les ai acquise
parce que je suis l'ami de monsieur
poutine
est-ce que je l'aï acquise parce que
j'ai eu des privatisations favorables
comme le l'homme qui était plus riche de
l'histoire de ces dernières années c'est
un mexicain qui s'appelle carlos slim
il a bénéficié d'énormément de
privatisations très avantageuse qui
l'ont rendu le plus riche est ce que
c'est une richesse bien acquise
je n'en suis pas convaincu on pourrait
citer les politiques de restrictions
foncière qui font augmenter les
inégalités en france on pourrait citer
la politique de la banque centrale
européenne qui spolie les épargnants au
profit des plus riches dont il ya tout
un tas d'inégalités qui elles sont
illégitimes
parce qu'elles relèvent d'un non
consentement entre individus si on reste
un peu sur la logique philosophie on
peut ne pas oublier ce qu en 1919 la
plus vieille organisation internationale
qui existe qui est l'oit et le bio
l'intention du travail on était sur une
traction du travail qu'ils aient il n'ya
pas de paix durable sans justice sociale
disait ça et on l'a rappelé à la
déclaration de philadelphie en 44 comme
quoi c'était nécessaire et on a eu un
exemple dans l'histoire c'est à dire que
le président roosevelt ne voulait pas
revoir les inégalités de 1928 ça ne
faisait pas plaisir et on voit la
fiscalité américaine des années 50
jusqu'aux années soixante dix où les
dernière tranche de l'impôt sur le
revenu sont taxés jusqu'à 76 80 % et
même roosevelt a abandonné avait évoqué
91% en est ce que les états unis ont
n'ont pas connu de croissance à l'époque
non est-ce que effectivement les
inégalités entre américains sont élevés
oui et en fait si vous voulez ce que je
lis qui me paraît fou aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on puisse revenir sur un acquis qui
me semblait essentiel des lendemains la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est pas est ce
que vaut mieux l'économique
social c'était l'idée que les deux
devaient tenir ensemble et c'est à dire
que faire la prospérité économique sur
la misère sociale n'était pas possible
ça c'est quelque chose qui me paraît
absolument essentiel à garder à l'esprit
alors bien sûr alors si on voulait
convoquer l'histoire parce qu évoqué
l'histoire
marx lui même disait qu effectivement le
capitalisme ne volait pas il l'exploité
ce qui n'est pas la même chose puisque
effectivement il dégageait de la plus
value et qu'est ce que c'était la plus
value c'est la différence entre le
travail que le capital
l'ouvrier fait et le surtravail taille
en fait ils travaillent plus qui
nécessaire pour sa reproduction du
travailleur comme on disait
et que cette plus value est récupéré par
le capitaliste c'est ce que disait très
bien l'économiste a rod y lisait le
capitaliste gagne ce qu'ils dépensent et
l'ouvrier dépend ce qu'il gagne c'est
c'est une formule qui est qui est
remarquable parce qu'effectivement ça
veut dire bien ce que ça veut dire c'est
à dire qu'ils achètent de la force de
travail il achète de l'outillage ça lui
rapporte quelque chose et il donne un
ouvrier qui lui ne peut que dépenser ce
qu'ils gagnent donc ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que en tant que tel on peut
concilier les deux c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il s'agit pas d'être
tout le monde à égalité
anna lipietz avait une très bonne
formule pour indiquer un petit peu la
logique à l'oeuvre dans les trente
glorieuses c'était la métaphore de
l'escalator
c'est à dire ils disaient que tout le
monde se trompe quand on observe
quelqu'un sur un escalator tout le monde
certains sont en balles d'autres os mais
tout le monde est emporté par le même
mouvement vers le haut et bien ce qui
explique que un ouvrier pouvait espérer
dans sa vie active rejoindre
progressivement le niveau d'un cadre
aujourd'hui les écarts maintenant pour
pouvoir rattraper le niveau de vie
nakhal sont parfois de 150 ans donc ce
qui devient de plus en plus compliqué le
cas en france 6 et si c'est le cas en
france
voilà mais est mis en garde le pays
numéro 10 est beaucoup moins
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est à
dire que les états unis qu'on a souvent
présenté comme un pays ultra libérale on
a oublié cette phase où ils ont utilisé
beaucoup plus que nous l'impôt sur le
revenu l'impôt progressif l'impôt
progressif pour pouvoir réduire les
inégalités et qui explique qu' un des
enseignements de la crise de 29
un double enseignement c'est que à une
croissance fondée sur une excessive
financiarisation n'est pas durable et
une croissance fondée sur les inégalités
n'ont plus est ce qui explique pourquoi
après guerre il s'est agi de concilier
autant que possible avec la menace
communiste qui étaient là est bien
présente effectivement et bien l'idéal
économique et social et qui fait qu'on a
pu avoir une réduction des inégalités et
avec en même temps de la croissance donc
là n'est pas antinomique de l'autre
pascal salin
oui je crois qu'il ne faut pas oublier
une chose fondamentale à savoir que les
êtres humains sont complémentaires du
point de vue des activités productives
les salariés ne peuvent pas gagner des
salaires élevés ne peuvent pas avoir
d'emploi sipa d'entrepreneurs et donc en
voulant faire une redistribution qui
atteint trop ceux qui sont les plus
productifs et bien on lui a tout le
monde sait c'est pourquoi pour ma part
je suis totalement critique de la
progressivité de l'impôt parce qu'elle
conduit à cette situation qui à le
détruire les incitations à entreprendre
est par ailleurs d'ailleurs ceux qui
bénéficient gratuitement de le service
public
ils sont moins incités à faire des
efforts également pour produire
donc c'est sa liberté des échanges que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure qui est qui
et efficace etc et morale la moralité
c'est celle qui consiste à respecter
les activités des gens leur droit de
propriété olivier berruyer comme vous le
disais tout à l'heure on ferait
rappelons aussi l'exemple des etats-unis
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale le
taux marginal est monté à plus de 90% et
juste après il était à 81 à 70 %
il me semble que ça n'a pas beaucoup nui
à la croissance aux états unis comme un
bel exemple que évidemment des indes est
un des taux marginaux élevé ne nuisent
pas la croissance si vous faites le
contraire sinon c'est moi qui vais
subventionné marc darnault pour le
remercier on n'en est plus très long
mais moi ce qui me frappe c'est qu'on ne
cesse de nous dire et au fini par croire
que des inégalités n'ont jamais été
aussi grandes que à l'heure actuelle et
encore une fois on nous sort des
chiffres toujours astronomiques pour le
prouver
or l'europe et les états unis en gros le
monde blanc représentait 30% de la
population mondiale au début du 20e
siècle et à ce moment-là ça représentait
je crois 80 % du commerce mondial cédé
juste entre les états unis et l'europe
80% du commerce mondial à l'époque on
avait colonisé je crois
la moitié de la population mondiale de
par ce qu'ont été les plus nombreux mais
aussi les plus riches et qu'on devait à
ce moment-là captait à peu près
monopolisé à peu près l'équivalent 80%
de la richesse mondiale pas seulement du
commerce est aujourd'hui on sait que
l'asie c'est près de la moitié du pnb et
on sait aussi que l'europe et les états
unis ça représente je crois - 12 15 %
d'un delà de la population mondiale mais
je crois que nous conservons donc rien
que là on voit bien que les aider
les inégalités se sont considérablement
réduites entre le mood blanc telle qu'on
l'appelle aujourd'hui et le reste de la
population par rapport à il ya un siècle
or nous dit que les inégalités sont plus
criantes que jamais nous c'est le
contraire elle était criante au début du
20e siècle
elles le sont de moins en moins mais ça
dépend si vous comparez comme j'ai tout
à l'heure à ce que c'est une comparaison
au niveau de la planète est ce que c'est
une comparaison au niveau d'une société
donc d'un pays vous avez raison il ya
une anomalie historique de toute façon
il n'y a pas de raison que la part du
pib mondial d'un pays soit très
différent de la portion de la population
à terme
alors effectivement c'est ce qu'il y
avait 1 de lens 0 jusqu'à l'an 1600 à
peu près ils ont zappé avant la
révolution industrielle tout va bien sûr
c'était que de l'agriculture donc
vraiment c'est un prorata du nombre de
personnes et puis on vous avait une
anomalie très forte pendant deux à trois
siècles qui en effet cette émergence de
l'europe puis des états unis qui capte
la balle à kasserine anomalies mais que
chaque chorale au contraire plus créatif
plus produire du riz c'est tout à fait
ça dépend où on se passe mais est
quelque chose qui va pas durer puisque
il faut croire que finalement les autres
se mettent à depuis produire encore
aujourd'hui l'un des trois ans je crois
un pour cent de la population mondiale
mais 4% du pib et du pnb donc ces
différences existent encore mais par
rapport à il ya un siècle
ah ben ça s'est considérablement réduite
ou si on avait regardé ça il ya un
siècle la france avec son empire
colonial c'était bien plus que 4% du pnb
mondial on est bien tous et réduit leur
en kabylie tout à fait là c'est en fait
ce que vous soulevez c'est cette vision
du gâteau fixe c'est de croire que
l'économie est un gâteau fixe et que
s'il y en a qui en prennent une grande
partie c'est qu'ils le font au détriment
des autres alors que l'enjeu c'est de
faire grossir ce gâteau est ce gâteau
avec la révolution industrielle a grossi
énormément et continue de grossir
aujourd'hui plus les pays
s'ouvre à l'économie de marché et donc
c'est vraiment essentiel de d'abandonner
cette idée vraiment très très marxiste
qui est de dire que l'économie c'est un
gâteau fixe l'économie c'est un gâteau
qui grossit et si vous voulez enrichir
les gens il faut que le gâteau
grossistes mais elles seront pas dire
autre question que le gâteau a grossi
que finalement je regarde le monde
d'aujourd'hui est bien plus riche qui a
un siècle que sûr que au fond tous les
pays où la plupart se sont
considérablement enrichis maps à rien
fait mais que néanmoins les inégalités
ou d'augmenter parce que si vous
augmentez tout le monde de 10% admettons
ce qui n'est pas le cas mais cela était
pareil
bah celui qui avait 10 enfin celui qui
avait 50 tout à coup se retrouve avec 55
celui qui avait dit se retrouve à 11 et
bien et tout le monde s'est enrichie de
10 % mais les inégalités se sont
creusées creusé entre 11 et 55 le groupe
contre dix et sa coordination enfin la
métaphore du gâteau c copyr ight alain
madelin 1986 moi je l'entende que je
suis tout petit 1 ce qui se passe
maintenant s'il ya plus de croissance
vous remarquez donc le gâteau et grossit
plus mais par contre les paras
l'intérieur à des plus riches ils
augmentent donc c'est ça le problème
il ya dans certains pays des limitations
de la croissance il faut se poser des
question de l'origine de cette
limitation
ils ne sont certainement pas du côté des
institutions qui organisait avant
l'économie de marché qui organise
l'économie de marché aujourd'hui sur
neil des inégalités qui augmente
notamment en france par exemple sur le
patrimoine
c'est lié par exemple à des restrictions
foncière qui font que l'on peut pas
suffisamment construire donc les prix
explosent ce qui favorise les insider
les plus âgés dans les grandes
métropoles au détriment des jeunes
primo-accédants qui trouvent des prix du
logement qui ont qui ont un instinct des
sommes délirantes
il ya un autre facteur qui est la
politique monétaire alors pascal sala on
parlerait bien mieux que moi mais
aujourd'hui la politique monétaire
organise une sorte de robin des bois à
l'envers en fonctionnant le revenu des
salariés des épargnants en faisant une
création monétaire qui va favoriser les
plus riches les grandes entreprises ou
les états les états qui sourd qui
s'endettent énormément et donc ça c'est
une forme de robin des bois à l'envers
qui il est vrai est là je rejoins mais
je rejoins le constat sur lequel
aujourd'hui on a une situation en france
qui est relativement préoccupante
là est pour moi le logement est
essentiel enfin si la halle la crise des
gilet jaune peut en partie s'expliquer à
mon avis par ces inégalités de fortune
dit aussi le pouvoir d'achat qui a
relativement stagné mais le facteur
essentiel c'est le logement est le
résultat de ce que je pense et des
politiques foncières très réglementé qui
empêchent de construire là on en a
besoin et qui empêchent de construire en
hauteur et ce qui met au ban de la
société
les jeunes les moins qualifiés et ça
c'est vraiment l'enjeu principal en
france qui devrait être le coeur du
débat des municipales mais il suffit de
ce point de vue là critiquable puisque
et il incite à ne pas développer des
logements peu plusieurs remarques
c'est à dire qu'il faut quand même
garder à l'esprit arcade on observe un
peu l'histoire encore une fois ce que
l'histoire c'est quand même riche
d'enseignements alors une phase qui est
pourtant peut-être pas là la phase là la
plus formidable pour le capitalisme qui
va de 1920 à 1970 avec effectivement bon
croissance après la première guerre
mondiale interrompue par une grande
crise mais ensuite la seconde guerre
mondiale dans cette période les échanges
internationaux connaissent une certaine
contraction évidente est que le gat
après la seconde guerre mondiale donc à
entraîner une ouverture qui nous vaut
lente des économies mais on n'avait pas
retrouvé des degrés d'ouverture avant
qu'ils étaient comparables à ceux de la
fin du 19e siècle et dans cette même
période on observe quoi en terme de
réduction des inégalités une réduction
des inégalités au moment même où il ya
cette contraction
donc pourquoi parce que après la seconde
guerre mondiale si on raisonne en
employant le terme de capitalisme comme
les capitalisme qui sont portés à
l'expansion vers l'étranger se sont
rétractés sur les sphères nationales
on a développé des régimes de croissance
qui ont eu pour vocation de faire naître
une demande intérieure solvables et donc
il ya tout un débat en économie qui est
le suivant est ce que les échanges
mondiaux après la guerre c'est eux qui
ont tiré la croissance
ou bien parce qu'il y avait une demande
intérieure suffisamment dynamique qui
attirait les échanges mondiaux est donc
ce ce débat là est loin d'être clos en
économie sur cette question c'est à dire
le sens de la corrélation
c'est vrai dans un sens ou dans l'autre
ça ses premiers éléments que je
souhaiterais garde est allé à l'esprit
ce qui me paraît essentiel deuxième
élément par rapport au droit de
propriété
je crois que la modernité c'était de
sortir de la propriété du premier régime
de propriété qui était très
astreintes en tant que tel à un deuxième
deux types de propriétés qui venus l'a
complété que robert castel appelé très
intelligemment la propriété sociale
c'est à dire donner des droits sociaux à
ceux qui n'étaient pas des propriétaires
leur permettant effectivement une
amélioration de leur situation et de
participer à l'activité économique et
dernière petite chose sur gâteau et
ruissellement
même si la métaphore du gâteau est un
peu insupportable je suis d'accord il ya
deux positions
soit on se dit il faut faire croître le
gâteau soit on peut se dire
gardons le gâteau tel qu'il est mais en
fait enrichissons comme on dit ceux qui
sont les plus parlées plus importante
parce qu'après ça ruisselle rassure les
autres alors je pense qu'il me paraît
plus souhaitable de réfléchir à comment
augmenter le gâteau que d'espérer un vin
ruissellement des plus riches vers les
moyens mais eux et tout le monde et
parce que c'est ça l'enseignement de
l'histoire c'est qu'effectivement on
peut concilier une réduction des
inégalités avec une croissance robuste
et c'est ce que nous a montrée
effectivement les lendemains de l'après
guerre et qui fait qu' on s'est retrouvé
pendant une vingtaine d'années avec
quasiment aucune crise financière
majeure et il a fallu attendre
effectivement la deuxième mondialisation
c'est à dire la fin des années 70 c'est
le début et qui accélère entre 90 et
2000 pour voir quoi
certes de la croissance mais la
multiplication aussi des crises et cette
question qui se pose à nouveau qui est
inégalités ou non et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui que l'on puisse à nouveau
se dire l'économique doit primer sur le
social au lieu de repenser ce compromis
travail capital
en dix ans les deux doivent tenir
ensemble me paraît un peu problématique
mais alors je ne crois pas qu'on est que
la chine se sont enrichis avec un
salaire minimum une sécurité sociale
c'est vraiment l'économie de marché
l'ouverture de zones franches qui fait
que la chine s'est dirigé mais
j'aimerais juste répondre sur sur sur la
question des droits de propriété parce
que derrière il ya un discours
anticapitaliste en 2010 mohamed bouazizi
s'immole par le feu en tunisie il
déclenché le printemps arabe
c c'est ce qui va déclencher les
révoltes dans tout un tas de pays du
monde arabo musulman
pourquoi est-ce qui s'est immolé par le
feu s'est immolé par le feu parce que ça
faisait sept ans il était vendeur
d'orange sur
avec une charrette sur sur un marché
tunisien et ça faisait sept ans qui
demandait l'autorisation de pouvoir
acheter une camionnette pour pas avoir
la tirait à bout de bras et ça faisait
sept ans que les bureaucrates locaux
l'empêcher de vendre sur le marché lui
interdisait justement ce droit de
propriété de ces oranges régulièrement
menées lui confisquer sa marchandise lui
taxé sont revenus et donc c'est vraiment
le la négation de ses droits
fondamentaux qui sont les libertés
économiques
le droit de propriété le droit
d'échanger avec qui je souhaite le droit
de posséder les fruits de mon travail
qui sont aujourd'hui la raison pour
laquelle des gens restent enfermés dans
la pauvreté il faut vraiment regarder le
lire le livre de fernando soto qui
savaient le mystère du capital qui
montre que c'est à partir du moment où
des individus se révoltent et disposent
de leur capital le capital c'est la tête
le la tête du buzz des vaches qu'on
détient qu'on reconnaît le droit de
détenir ces animaux là parce qu on est
paysan avant l'été sert rooney est ce
droit là vraiment on le détient qu'on a
le droit de les changer qu'on a droit de
gagner en productivité et qu'on réclame
ses droits là le monde s'enrichit la
société s'enrichit alors il y en a qui
vont s'enrichir en premier c'est pour ça
que des inégalités augmentent les autres
rattraperont dans un second temps ce qui
crée des frustrations qui ce qui crée
des ressentiments
il faut vraiment comprendre le mécanisme
est le mécanisme initial c'est d'abord
reconnaître ses droits de propriété là
aujourd'hui il ya des cas ce temps
l'inde qui se bat pour qu'on le
reconnaisse le droit les caisses des
intouchables notamment qu'on leur
reconnaisse le droit de posséder leur
terre ils n'ont pas le droit on leur on
ne le reconnaît pas ce droit là et c'est
à partir du moment où on leur reconnaît
ce droit là et qu'on croit d'ailleurs le
mesurer parce que sinon on peut pas le
mesurer qu'on reconnaît le cadastre le
capitalisme droit de propriété que le
monde s'enrichit ça a commencé comme ça
où à la fin du moyen-âge en europe en
italie
là où les féodalités n'existait pas
parce qu'il a fait d'hériter c'était
l'année des gassion du droit de
propriété la condition nécessaire c'est
d'abord la liberté économique juste
minutes parce que c'est la femme qui
était jugé il s'agit pas d'être contre
la propriété c'est pas la propriété ou
sinon le collectivisme c'est pas ça
c'est que cette première propriété
effectivement on peut tout à fait la
défendre elle peut être enrichie par une
propriété complémentaires que castel
appel propriété sociale mais ce que je
veux bien garder à l'esprit c'est que on
peut avoir un discours de critiquer par
exemple été le disque
au keynésien qu'il s'agissait pas de
renverser le capitalisme qui a été un
discours au contraire qui en faisant en
sorte de réduire les inégalités faire la
redistribution ça eu pour effet de
légitimer le capitalisme ils n'ont pas
de le dénoncer
donc au contraire aller dans les aspects
les plus destructeur du capitalisme
eh bien ça me paraît fou pour ceux qui
veulent le défendre parce que finalement
c'est le délégitiment aux yeux du plus
grand nombre d'animaux face à la wii je
voudrais souligner que tous les
individus ou presque tous envie
d'améliorer leur sort et font des
efforts pour ça une fois de plus ce
qu'on doit critiquer dans cette notion
consistante à mesurer les inégalités
c'est quand t'as pas compte du temps il
ya eu des études nombreuses qui ont été
faites aux états unis qui ont étudié
l'évolution dans le temps des mêmes
individus et je n'ai pas les chiffres en
tête parfaitement mais c'est même très
frappant kent est une très grande
proportion de ceux qui sont pauvres
à une époque un certain nombre d'années
plus tard son âme appartient dans la
catégorie des riches est d'ailleurs
inversement aussi il ya une évolution
dans les la richesse des gens dans leurs
revenus dans leur capital et il faut
laisser cette liberté cette possibilité
est bas une fois de plus tous eu tout ce
que l'on dit à propos de les inégalités
néglige totalement ce fait fondamental
qui est l'évolution le long de la vie
des gens voulaient ajouter les choses
que la statistique c'est qu'un américain
sur deux fera partie un jour des 10% les
plus riches
c'est pour fondamentale
l'évolution est l'importance de prendre
en compte le temps qualité exemple
justement dont parle un petit peu oxfam
au niveau des retraites macron vient de
dire qu' il ne pouvait pas augmenter les
retraites minimales l'un des
agriculteurs à 1000 euros par mois que
c'était trop un rom est l'impôt sur la
fortune 3 milliards c'est 300 euros par
mois pour 1 million d'agriculteurs
retraités
ah c'est ça aussi la redistribution une
d'une belle mentalité compatible avec
oxfam ces trois milliards d'euros reculé
du capital productif qui vont générer de
l'emploi qui vont générer de l'emploi on
a bien besoin en france plutôt que de
faire une redistribution qui va
peut-être favorisé pendant un temps
court ces personnes là mais c'est pas
durable c'est le même calcul que vous
faisiez quand vous disiez si on divise
tous les cas on arrive à des milliards
da ça fera 400 euros et ça ne produira
rien exactement et ses premières sont
partis dans les circuits financiers
un taux négatif dans tout à l'heure vous
dénoncez la pole on est d'accord mais il
faut d'abord dénonce la seconde on se
retrouve toujours dans cette espèce
d'antinomie il y aurait l'économie qui
précéderait le social il faudrait que
social attendre que l'économie hagist je
pense qu'il faut relier les deux c'est
comme séparer artificiellement
l'individu et la société alors dit
qu'est-ce qui commencent à avancer
l'individu puis la société où la société
puis l'individu
norbert elias avait raison de dire nous
sommes dans une société d'individus
c'est plus simple comme ça et tout comme
l'économique et le social ne doivent pas
se séparer et donc penser que ont fait
de l'économique et qu'on fait les comics
et productif quand on fait du social
c'est improductif
non linder tu quittes un économiste
américain a bien montré que l'état
providence a rapporté plus qu'il n'a
coûté il a parlé même la théorie des
frais free lunch pour dire que
finalement c'est comme si on l'avait
obtenue grâce à ça des repas gratuits
voilà je veux remercier tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez-vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]